SPEAKER 1: Hello, and welcome
to Mental Health Matters,
Strategies for Managing
Anxiety and Feeling Happier.
Thanks to all of our
participants who are joining us
from more than 80
countries around the world.
This webinar is brought
to you by Harvard Online.
We are excited to introduce you
to our moderator and panelists
for this event, Anna Bartuska,
Dr. Luana, and Michael.
Without further ado, let's
begin our discussion.
Anna, the virtual floor is yours.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Thank you.
Welcome, everyone, and we are
delighted to have you with us today.
My name is Anna Bartuska, and
I'm a clinical psychology PhD
student at the University of Oregon.
It is an honor and a pleasure
to introduce to you today
two extraordinary experts that
will be guiding our conversations.
First is Michael Puett.
Michael Puett is the Walter C.
Klein Professor of Chinese History
and Anthropology at Harvard University.
His interests are focused
on the interrelations
between history, anthropology,
religion, and philosophy,
with the hope of bringing
the study of China
into larger historical and
comparative frameworks.
He is the author of The
Path, A New Way to Think
About Everything, The
Ambivalence of Creation,
Debates Concerning Innovation
and Artifice in Early China,
and To Become God, Cosmology, Sacrifice,
and Self-Divination in Early China.
In addition, he is the course
faculty for Harvard Online's course,
"The Path To Happiness."
We also have with us today, Dr. Luana.
Dr. Luana is an Associate Professor
at Harvard Medical School,
Founder and Director of Community
Psychiatry Program for Research
and Implementation and Dissemination
of Evidence-Based Treatments
at Massachusetts General Hospital,
and former President of the Anxiety
and Depression Association of America.
Dr. Luana is frequently cited
as one of the leading experts
in cognitive behavioral therapies.
She's been featured in publications,
such as The New York Times, CNN,
and Harvard Business Review.
She's also been a regular
guest on television broadcasts,
such as Good Morning America, and
podcasts, including Ten Percent
Happier.
Dr. Luana is the author of
Bold Move, A 3-Step Plan
to Transform Anxiety
into Power, which has
been lauded for its clear and practical
approach to dealing with anxiety,
and will be released
officially next Tuesday.
Dr. Luana is the course faculty
for Harvard's Online course,
"Building Personal Resilience,
Managing Anxiety and Mental Health."
Michael and Luana, we are so excited
to have you both here with us today
to talk about mental health
and living a good life.
To begin, I would love
to hear from each of you
how you became interested in this topic.
Michael, do you want to kick us off?
MICHAEL PUETT: I'll be happy to.
Thank you, it's such an honor
to be here with the two of you,
and with the larger group.
I got interested in this topic just
because I was doing two things.
I was reading a lot of Chinese
philosophy, and I was living my life.
And like for many of us, living
my life with was not always easy.
And meanwhile, I was
reading a body of philosophy
that gave extremely
practical advice for what
one could do on literally
a daily basis in one's most
sort of mundane aspects of living.
And so my excitement
really started there.
I decided these texts were
probably onto something,
and these practices
really would be revealing.
And that began my path
that has led here.
ANNA BARTUSKA: I appreciate your
openness to share your own journey,
and we hope to hear a little
bit more about that today, too.
Dr. Luana, what brought you to
become interested in this topic?
LUANA MARQUES: Thank you,
Anna, for moderating.
It's so nice to be here
with you as well, Michael.
For me, it's been a transition
really from Brazil to the US.
Not until very recently, I realized
that I grew up as a very anxious kid.
And it was really tough growing up.
There was a lot of adversity,
a lot of trauma in my home.
And my mom really did the best she could
to get us out of our humble beginnings
and into the US.
And I realized at about
age 15, that I was, well,
my grandmother, let's be honest, not
I. At 15, I had no insight in this.
My grandmother really caught
me avoiding a lot of things.
And it pushed me to do what's
now known as exposure therapy.
And at that point, she really
changed the trajectory of my life.
And I remember coming to the US, first
trying to become a medical doctor,
get an MD.
And I was in Brazil talking to my
grandmother, talking about how much
I love the brain, and
how much I love science,
how much I wanted to
sort of help people.
And she's like, why don't
you take a psychology class?
And so I did.
I took psychology class, and
it just made sense in my brain.
It's almost like the
things that she had taught
me now made sense scientifically.
And I never looked back.
The rest became history.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Thank you for sharing.
It seems like mental health has
been a topic for many, many years,
from ancient Chinese philosophy,
also throughout the duration of both
of your lives.
And yet, we're seeing
such a rise in terms
of mental health being talked
about in news and on social media
and other platforms.
Can you shed some light as to why we're
seeing that uptick of mental health
being such a hot topic today?
Dr. Luana, you want to start?
LUANA MARQUES: Sure, I'd love to.
I don't know if it's just
a rise in mental health.
I think there's a couple
of things happening.
Since the pandemic, most of us have
had a moment that it was just too much.
And so there was no other way,
but to talk about brain health
and anxiety and sadness and loneliness.
So there is an increase on the
shared experience of things
that fall under mental health.
The CDC is showing 30% to 40% of people
suffering clinical levels of anxiety
and depression after the pandemic.
And so first I think there's
increasing awareness.
Second, increase of shared humanity.
And then I think our lives are
just changing dramatically.
And people are still not
sure how to transition fully.
We expected that our lives could go back
to sort of a new normal, so to speak.
But I think in many ways, we have
transitioned and need to readjust.
And that readjustment
hasn't happened as much.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Yeah.
You mentioned this word
anxiety, and we hear it a lot.
In your professional
opinion, what is anxiety?
LUANA MARQUES: So, I'm going to
share an example what anxiety is.
So, this morning, I was
getting ready for this panel,
and I looked at Michael's course, and I
was trying to learn more about Michael,
and I didn't a lot
about your work, Mike.
So I looked up, and we have
this new course coming up.
And so I looked at our course.
We had like 8,000 people registered, and
I was like, oh, this is really awesome.
And I looked at Michael's course, and
he had like 100,000 people registered,
so let's just be clear here.
And my brain went, oh, my God.
I'm totally messing up.
My course is not going to be successful.
I'm such a failure.
And so the first thing that happens,
we talk about anxieties, something
happens and our brain pretty
quickly distorts information.
And my brain at that
point, I had no capacity
to look how long Michael's
course was open, none of that.
I just had this
narrative of my brain of,
I am not good enough, which
started to make my heart pound.
And I was like, finish getting ready.
And I could sense this
vibration of anxiety,
and I was like, what
am I doing to myself?
And in fact, later on, I was talking
to Nicole, and I was like, so,
how long has Michael's course been open?
She's like, a year.
I was like, oh, OK, so
maybe I'm not that bad.
But that is sort of anxiety for you.
Like, our brains tend to misinterpret
data when we are anxious,
and jump to conclusions,
and catastrophize,
which is just what I did this morning.
So, Michael, I was not
trying to compare with you,
but my brain certainly wanted to.
[LAUGHS]
ANNA BARTUSKA: I know.
I almost dare to say that maybe
happiness is a little bit more
of a comfortable feeling than
anxiety when we think about it.
Michael, I want to toss it
over to you and to just hear
your thoughts of why mental health
has become such a hot topic,
and any thoughts you have about
anxiety or the other side of the coin
that we're all seeking,
happiness, as well.
MICHAEL PUETT: Absolutely.
And full agreement with Luana here.
I think that is exactly right.
We have gone through this period
for, of course, the pandemic,
which was devastating for so many of
us for all of the obvious reasons.
We have now been in a
world of social media
for 15 years that's having
a tremendous impact.
We're facing, obviously, a very
difficult structural future.
Climate change, rising inequality,
lack of social mobility.
So, a growing sense that the future
for us and the next generations
could be increasingly difficult.
So, all of those are playing
into the current rise of anxiety.
And, of course, the sad part of this,
is that although specific things I just
mentioned are new, much of this is not.
People have been wrestling with
difficulties of anxiety for, well,
thousands of years, which is why I'm
looking at text among other things that
are addressing issues that are
incredibly comparable to those
that we're currently wrestling with.
So, I think sadly, going back to Luana's
point, it's telling about the way
that our human brain and
our emotions operate.
We don't respond well to situations.
We invent very complex readings of
issues that are really uncalled for.
We fall into patterns of responses
that are oftentimes very debilitating.
And this is part of being human.
Now, that's the negative
way of putting it,
let me immediately say,
of course, the flipside
of that is we are capable
of breaking out of all
that I just mentioned, in terms of our
ways of responding to the world, which
is why, if these are typically
human bad ways of responding,
we are capable of responding very
effectively, which is exactly,
of course, what Luana
is showing in her work.
And yes, Luana, your course is
going to be incredibly successful,
as will your book.
LUANA MARQUES: Oh, thank you, Mike.
I love that though, I love, if I
may jump in, I love this piece of,
it is just the human condition.
And our brain is sort of wired
to protect and predict, and often
uses data mechanisms really to
make predictions, like my brain
this morning.
It's just based on growing up poor
and having this belief I'm not enough.
And now I'm an adult, I know
I'm enough, and yet, the brain
wants to malfunction.
So I love what you
said, Michael, which is,
we don't have to believe
that narrative, right?
There is ways to rewrite our brain.
And that's why I love what
you're talking about, as well.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Yeah.
It's really interesting to
hear you both talk about this,
this idea of pattern and responding.
My question to both of you is, if this
is just part of the human experience,
then when do we just kind
of continue on accepting
that it's part of the human experience
and when do we really start to change?
Or what do we do?
When does this become problematic,
and how do we know when that happens?
Either of you, whoever wants
to respond first, jump in.
LUANA MARQUES: Go for it, Michael.
MICHAEL PUETT: Sure.
I would say it is always problematic.
Part of what's sad about the human
condition, is we often don't see it.
So we see it when it hits a crisis
point, when our patterns just
continue to a point where it becomes a
devastating to those around us in ways
that we're forced to finally realize.
Or devastating to aspects of our
life in ways that we are again,
forced to realize.
But sadly, we are capable of living our
daily life with these patterns and just
kind of continuing day by day.
In fact, doing horrible things
to ourselves and those around us
without even seeing it.
And that can continue
for an entire life.
Now, again, that's the bad news.
The flip side of that
is, we are absolutely
capable of breaking out of this.
We are fully capable of doing so.
All of us in various moments of our
lives have successfully done so.
And so part of the goal,
is to develop practices
in which that becomes part of
our regular way of being, instead
of constantly falling back into
these patterns that are again,
so devastating, and yet, so
normalized in our way of living
that we tend not to even notice them.
We just think that's what life is,
or what we personally just are.
We're just unhappy creatures.
LUANA MARQUES: I love this,
Michael, I love this idea
that we have to sometimes hit this
wall and this crisis to see it.
And it doesn't have to be that way.
I think that's such an important message
for everybody listening to us today,
that you don't have to
get to the breaking point.
That, in fact, you can
catch this earlier.
And the signals are there.
I think when, I talk
a lot about anxiety,
and I think about anxiety
as a high fever, right?
It's calling your attention.
It's trying to tell you something.
But anxiety itself is not the problem.
It's what we do when we are
anxious that's the problem, right?
So for me, the example I
shared earlier today, I
shared not only to sort of share the
vulnerability of myself, but like I
wouldn't look for data, to
talk to Michael's point.
I was like, wait a minute,
like can I interpret this way
or is there another way to do this?
But I could have done the opposite.
I could have continued to
avoid, which by the way, then,
would make me super anxious
to be here with you.
And I love this point of number
one, we all can identify it,
and that we can catch it earlier
and change it in a daily basis.
I use CBT on myself every day.
And that's the only way to I
think to have a happy life.
ANNA BARTUSKA: There's so
much good happening right now.
I want to slow down the
conversation a little bit,
Luana, to what you just mentioned, about
this idea of anxiety being the fever.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about this term
that you use across your
work, psychological avoidance,
and how it fits into that analogy?
LUANA MARQUES: So, for the last
20 years of my career, everyone
that had come to work with me, be
it a big organization or individual,
they want me to get rid of anxiety,
just get rid of my anxiety.
But anxiety really is not
necessarily the problem.
In fact, we are biologically
wired to have a fear response.
So, I cannot magically get
somebody's anxiety completely gone.
In fact, it's like losing
your pain receptors.
If you touch a hot stove and
you don't have pain receptors,
it's a really big problem.
And so some level of
anxiety is expected.
The problem is what I call psychological
avoidance, which is anything
that we do to try to make
ourselves feel better momentarily,
but it has a long-term
negative consequence.
So I'm going to give an example.
If you are afraid of public speaking,
you might just pass on the promotion,
because you're so anxious, that
you just can't take that promotion.
If you want to go on a date, but
you're scared of other people,
you might not go on that date.
And so every time we avoid,
we are physically actually
training our brain that
we can't handle something.
And that is the real infection.
There were many moments in my
personal life that I'm terrified.
I was just speaking at Formula
1, and before I went on stage,
my heart felt like it was just
going to jump out of my chest.
But I approached, instead of avoided.
And so that's why I often say,
it's not anxiety, it's what we do.
And if what we do is avoid, we are
robbing ourselves of a good life.
ANNA BARTUSKA: That's
incredibly insightful.
I'm curious, Michael, how that
kind of relates to some of the work
that you've done in some of Chinese
philosophy and where it might diverge
or similar.
Any thoughts.
MICHAEL PUETT: Full agreement.
That is beautifully insightful.
And yes, so a lot of these texts
I deal with from early China
will say exactly the same thing.
So, the way they will
put it, is to say, we
will fall into patterns
of responding to the world
that we come just to
accept as who we are.
So Luana, going back
to your examples, I'll
just think, oh, I'm just
inherently bad at not.
That speaking publicly,
it's just not me.
And we'll even defend it with
terminology like, oh, that's just me
and I should learn to love and
embrace myself for who I am.
Loving my strengths, but
also loving my weaknesses.
And among my weaknesses are that
just I can't speak publicly.
And that's just me.
And so I should just find areas
of life where I can just be me,
and therefore, not
have to speak publicly.
And as you said, what we're doing
there, is just normalizing that.
We're taking these
patterns we've fallen into
and thinking that those
patterns themselves actually
are just us, that's just who I am.
And I agree with you fully.
Rather, what we should be doing, is a
daily practice where we're breaking out
of our patterns and,
sticking with your example,
if I feel I cannot speak publicly,
that's not because of who I am,
that's because I've fallen into a
pattern of just being incredibly
fearful of speaking publicly, for
perfectly understandable reasons.
But the way to do that is to
train oneself to speak publicly.
And like you, I would generalize this.
All of these things we just think
we can't do because of who we are,
realize these are probably just
patterns we've fallen into.
And all patterns are
changeable and are provable.
And the key is, it's a daily process
of just working through your patterns,
breaking your patterns, and having a
much better way of living in the world.
So I think the way you've put
it is absolutely beautiful.
LUANA MARQUES: I love this
part, Michael, on this idea
that we even rationalize our patterns.
I just think such a good, we create a
narrative, I call this like, my work,
I call this a pretzel effect.
That like we pretzel the
information just to fit a pattern.
But it doesn't really, if you say it
out loud, it doesn't make any sense.
In fact, if we're talking
to, if we talk to our friends
the way we talk to ourselves,
we would have no friends.
Because we are so mean!
Just to hold on to something
that makes no sense.
I love that piece.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Yeah.
I think that I completely agree.
We're going to open it up for
some audience questions here soon.
And we received some
questions in advance.
And I have one that I think really
fits into this conversation a bit.
So we've been talking a lot about this
idea of our patterns get us stuck.
They're part of what makes us human.
They aren't who we are, but our
patterns, particularly when we
avoid things, is some of what's leading
to lack of happiness or mental health.
A participant from Kenya
has asked, "How can I
differentiate between mental
health and normal life stress?"
Luana, you want you
want to start this one?
LUANA MARQUES: Sure.
I love that we have a
participant from Kenya.
So, I don't know who you
are, but that is awesome.
I'm so excited that you're
thinking about this.
And so, how do we
separate day to day stress
versus like getting to mental health?
And I imagine that
behind this question, is
this idea of am I just stressed, and
it's normal, and I can handle it,
versus like, when do I
also need to seek some help
and think about what it looks like.
And the way I always think
about this, and actually,
Michael said this a
little bit already, which
is, is this starting to
affect your day to day life.
Is it taking too much
energy to do things?
So often, usually when we're
talking about mental health
in the spectrum of
diagnosis, we're talking
about somebody that is
having trouble sleeping,
they're having trouble concentrating,
they are having trouble
engaging with the meaningful things.
And so the way I put
this very simply is,
what is the price tag
for you stress right now,
and who is paying that price tag?
Because often, we are
paying the price tag.
And I love that Michael
said this already.
We don't have to be stuck.
And so if you're sitting
around and you're wondering,
my suggestion is, it's
already had a price tag.
And so Michael's point
earlier, let's not
wait until it becomes a crisis,
which is usually most of us, ugh,
myself included, and that we
pay much bigger price tag.
Mike, I'd love to hear your
thoughts, too, on this.
MICHAEL PUETT: I agree completely.
This is both a wonderful question
and Luana, a wonderful answer.
So in full agreement, yes, I agree.
Often, the point where we
think our difficulties have
moved beyond normal stress
and reached a serious point,
is that point where indeed,
the patterns have played out
to an area where we can
no longer ignore them,
where we become clearly undeniably
harmful to ourselves or those
around us.
And as you said, Luana, the key is,
we want to try as much as possible.
We'll fail, but try as much
as possible to not get there.
Because even what we accept
as normal life, most of that
is going to be based upon these patterns
that we are dangerously falling into.
And if we're falling into
them on a daily basis,
and I think we are in general,
that's where on a daily basis,
we need to start working out of them.
And so going back to
Luana's point, we don't
want to wait until
something horrible happens.
The key is, we want to start
these daily practices right away
and begin working on our
patterns with hopefully,
realization that if we do so, we may
not as often reach those crisis points.
And also, as we go, I think we'll
realize what we often consider
to be normal stress isn't just normal.
It's just because we've rationalized
this as being the normal unhappiness
that we live with.
And maybe we shouldn't
be telling ourselves
we should be living with that
normal level of unhappiness.
So, full agreement, Luana, I
think that's a beautiful answer.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Yeah.
I really appreciate this.
We have a few more questions coming in,
which I'm so glad that they were asked,
because this is actually something
that I've been thinking, too.
So you mentioned that in a moment of
crisis, that this is really apparent.
Like if we're holding hot coffee
and it spills, it's clearly hot.
But sometimes when
we're holding the cup,
we don't actually realize what inside of
it is hot or is keeping our hands full
and actually creating a lot
of energy and drain from us.
So, we have kind of two
questions from the audience,
and I'm hoping that we can
kind of put them together.
Someone writes, "Is it possible
that we avoid frequently
for such a long period
of time, that we are
no longer even sure that we're avoiding,
and has become our way of being?"
And similarly related,
someone asks, "How do you
separate a pattern and who you are?
Where is the difference?"
And so, how do you identify
this before the moment of crisis
and you have coffee, hot coffee spilled
all over and you realize it's hot?
Either of you, whoever wants
to start, go ahead and jump in.
SPEAKER 1: Luana, go ahead.
LUANA MARQUES: I would jump
in on the avoidance one.
I love that question about avoidance,
because once the pattern is formed,
our brain, the way our brain is
wired, is to maintain the pattern.
And the reason being, is
it takes a lot less energy
to believe a distorted pattern than
to actually update your software.
Because when, Mike and I have
been talking about this idea
that we can change, and then we
have to start daily practice.
But it takes effort to do that.
And so once you've developed
an avoidance practice,
you tend to keep avoiding.
Let me give you an example.
For the longest time,
I thought I was just
very good at responding to emails fast.
The emails would come
and I just respond.
About five years ago, I
realized that what I was doing,
was avoiding my emotions.
An email'd come, upset me, instead of
being able to tolerate my discomfort,
I just would email really fast.
And then I would do what Michael said.
I would rationalize, well, I'm
just very fast and I'm very good.
But I was actually paying a price tag.
That's why avoidance is the problem.
Because eventually, somebody
called me in their office
and they're like, Luana, you don't
have to respond at midnight to an email
that you're clearly upset about.
Because what happens when I'm
responding, I'm just avoiding emotions.
And because I'm anxious, I'm
not in my thinking brain.
I'm on my emotional brain, which
means I'm not being logical correct.
And so the first piece is, if you are
asking the question, am I avoiding,
ask yourself one thing.
If I chose to go against that anxiety,
it's what I call opposite action.
So you're anxious.
And for me, imagine that I
want to answer that email.
If I don't answer, how would I feel?
And you should feel
slightly more anxious.
Because if you choose to
go opposite to the anxiety,
you're going to have discomfort.
But that kind of discomfort
is the discomfort
we're talking about,
sitting with your emotions,
so that you can actually
bring their temperature down.
And so that's how I personally separate.
I ask myself, you know, in my
dating days, which are long gone,
but I remember hating dating.
And I remember like my brain
saying, don't go on that date.
And if I were to ask
myself, if I go, am I going
to feel more or less uncomfortable?
And at first, I'd feel more
uncomfortable, but why would I do that?
Because I wanted to have a family.
I wanted to have a partner.
And so I then chose opposite action from
the avoidance to live a better life.
I think I took one of your questions.
I don't know if I took both, Anna.
I think I got too
excited about avoidance,
so I'm going to give it to Michael.
Maybe he can take the second question.
MICHAEL PUETT: I'll
be more than happy to.
So, wonderful answer.
And, yeah, I will then focus a
little bit more in the second,
although it's directly
related to the first as well.
So, let me say a few words about one
of the ideas that arises in early China
that I find really telling about this.
So, first, the contrast.
So certainly in America, but
this has now gone global,
we'll often use terminology
like the following.
We'll say, oh, I should spend my
life looking within finding myself,
finding my true self.
And part of that is with the
idea that we mentioned before,
learning to love and embrace
myself for who I really am.
Now, this sounds great.
It sounds like the way we
can liberate ourselves.
And going back to the second
part of the second question,
the focus would be what
you're finding there clearly
is your true self as opposed to these
patterns that we're falling into.
So, let me give a contrasting way
of pointing it from early China.
A very standard idea that will arise
in early China is, we are messes.
We are a mess of stuff when we are born.
We are a mess of emotions,
desires, faculties, energies,
and we're all equally messes.
And then what we become over time,
depends on what we do in life.
Patterns we fall into, practices we
fall into, conventions we are born into,
which means, going back to the
heart of the second question,
much of what we often think is
being our true self, the real me,
think of as very likely a bunch of
patterns that you've fallen into.
Now, that of course, gets to the
heart of that second question, which
is OK, well, if that's true,
is there no self there?
And the answer is, there definitely is.
But the self is what you make of it.
Which means, think of your life
as you creating and constructing
an extraordinary self, the way
you would construct a work of art,
but not in the final moment
when the art is done.
But it's a lifelong process where you
are becoming something extraordinary,
something beyond what you
could currently imagine,
which means again, going back to
that second question, what you're
doing on a daily basis is not
finding that true self that's
perfectly acceptable if you're
miserable, but it's you.
You're assuming most of the
patterns you're falling into
can be worked on and tweaked
and changed and altered.
And what you will become out of
that process, that's the self.
The self is what you
create through this work.
And it means, getting back to the
heart of Luana's arguments here,
what you're doing is
breaking out of your patterns
and learning to really
work with the world,
build extraordinary relationships in
ways that your patterns will never
allow you to do.
And as long as we keep thinking
those patterns are just who we are,
we will never be able to break out of.
LUANA MARQUES: I love
that picture of your life
is this painting that's
evolving over time.
And is like, in every day, when
you paint a little corner of it,
it sheds a little more light.
Just such a great image, thank you.
ANNA BARTUSKA: It is a great image.
It reminds me of when I was
a kid, you know, and you only
have the small 12-pack of crayons,
and then over time, you get more,
and that's like a really
exciting experience.
I really also appreciate
about your response, Michael,
that you started to talk about
the hopeful side of this.
The opportunity to
change for the better.
And it really aligns
with one of the questions
that we just received from the audience,
that's talking about mental peace.
And so, that more positive light.
So the question is, "Is mental peace
based on respecting others patterns,
or should we push past them
to scramble that pattern?"
And in parentheses, "just thinking about
family members or partners or friends."
Michael, what are your initial
thoughts to this question?
MICHAEL PUETT: Yes, what
a wonderful question.
And the way I'd like
to address it is, let
me give a couple of analogies, which
might sound like a very weird answer,
but bear with me for a few sentences.
So, are we capable of
doing the kinds of work
that Luana and I are talking about?
And the answer is, absolutely.
Just think of arenas in our lives
where we do things like this.
If you've ever learned a musical
instrument, it's a lot of work.
You spend years and years
and years training yourself.
But if you succeed after those
years by really doing it,
you can become an extraordinary
musician, either professional, or even
just an amateur, who can feel the
music, feel the fellow players,
feel the audience.
We're capable of it.
Sports, same thing.
None of us are born able to bounce
a basketball or kick a soccer ball.
We spend years doing
this and we can train
ourselves to become extraordinary.
If we are capable of doing this, then
the question would be, why in the world
don't we do this for our daily life?
We know we are capable
of training ourselves
to sense the world better,
relate to people better, connect
with people better.
We just don't do it.
Now again, that may seem like a
bizarre answer to the question,
but now let me return
to the heart of it.
What this would mean is,
if you're in a family,
do you simply scramble your patterns and
try to become a radically new person?
No, that would be kind of
like sitting down at the piano
before you've done your
lessons and playing randomly.
It would not be fun for you,
and very painful for the people
who had to listen.
What it would mean, on
the contrary is, you're
learning to really relate
to your family members.
You're learning to sense
them in their complexity.
You're learning not to simply respond
to them by rote pattern, which
is sadly, the way we often do.
You're training yourself to
really learn to listen to them,
and therefore, grow through
those relationships.
You're doing the same thing with
your friends, with the larger world.
And it's literally the same sort of
work we do if we're learning a sport
or learning a musical instrument.
It's about learning to, in
this case, listen to them,
sense them, grow from them, work with
them, grow through those relationships.
And what will happen with
your family if you do this?
It won't be really
scrambling up the patterns.
It will mean you'll
really relate to them.
And you will really build
extraordinary relationships,
which mean you and they will grow in
ways you could not now even imagine.
And it's daily work.
It's a lot of work.
But like when you're learning a
musical instrument, it's at first,
it seems like a lot of work.
But then it comes and
becomes incredibly exciting.
And I would say it's all the
more so with relationships.
As the relationships become
deeper and you're more connected,
it just, it's like a snowball effect,
where it just builds on itself
and you just want to keep
building that relationship.
And going back to the metaphor
of the work of art, again,
you're forming a work
of art in a way that
goes beyond what you could
have imagined it would be,
but it's the process
that is so extraordinary.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Yeah.
Thank you for answering that.
We've had, actually, a lot of
questions come in about really
how to support others.
Dr. Luana, I wonder if you could add
a little bit more to this kind of,
if we're playing for learning to play
soccer, what is the first step of what
we should do to really support others
who are struggling with anxiety
or just feeling unhappy
in their everyday life?
LUANA MARQUES: Sure.
I love what you said, Michael, because
really imagine a world for a second
that people would spend as much
time training their brain as they
do their physical body.
We have guidelines for how much exercise
we should get, and for a good health,
we have to exercise this many
days a week for those numbers.
But nobody talks about
training our brain.
And so this idea, I think
that's what I heard you say,
Michael, you need to train your
brain, and it is a lot of work.
Let's not lie about it.
It's a lot of work.
But anything meaningful
is a lot of work.
You don't get a degree
without a lot of work,
you don't learn how to play the
piano without a lot of work.
And so to just go to your
question, Anna, supporting others,
the first thing we need
to do is first make sure
that we are supporting ourselves.
Because often, I hear that question
about family members and others,
and you support them, but you,
yourself, are not living your best life.
Your self is not training your brain.
And so what happens is, what
Michael has been talking about,
you just spin with each other instead
of actually being able to do something.
So this is my secret power
when things are spinning.
Pause.
I mean it.
Just pause.
Because if your family member is
spinning, and often what we do is,
we try to just go fix it.
People need to be able to
have their own emotions.
People need to be able to learn
to manage their own emotions.
So one, is just pause and
observe what's happening.
Check your own narrative in your brain.
What are you saying to yourself
about what's happening?
And the other one is this.
If you want to really
support a family member,
ask them what they
need in terms of help.
We're very creative about
what we think people need.
And we often don't ask what they need.
And sometimes, it's like, I
said to my husband yesterday.
He's like, what do you
want for Mother's Day?
I'm like, a nap in the sun in
the hammock, that's all I want.
He could have done a
million things for me.
That was the only thing I wanted.
And because he asked, he was able
to go play soccer with our son,
and I was able to take my
nap, and it was just perfect.
And so pause and ask are my two
recommendations for family members.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Dr. Luana, do you
have any tricks for how to pause?
I can imagine that would be so hard
if you really want to do something
or really want to help someone.
How do we actually pause?
LUANA MARQUES: Avoidance wants
you to do something always.
It's always ordering you around.
So, here's a trick.
When we are anxious or stressed,
we are in our limbic system,
we are in fight, flight, or freeze.
We're in anxious brain, which is going
to command you to try to do something.
What we know from cognitive behavioral
therapy, is even the act of writing,
so imagine that you're really anxious.
Putting down your thoughts, linking
thoughts to emotions and to behaviors,
just by writing simply,
you're actually activating
your prefrontal cortex,
the part of your brain
that allows you to slow
down, to execute, to plan.
And so sometimes I am so anxious, that
I can't even think of why I'm anxious.
I'm like, my brain is spinning.
I literally take my journal and
I just write down the thoughts
until I get to oh, this is the thought.
Usually for me is, I'm not enough.
And then I go oh,
that's that old belief.
I don't have to do this anymore.
So just writing, it's
like an awesome trick.
The other one is going to
sound so odd to many people,
but I'm going to tell you a
secret from dialectical behavior
therapy that's super
effective, especially
if you have a toddler at home, like
I do, who at times is melting down.
And in dialectical
behavior therapy, when
you really, really, really stress,
one technique they use is you
hold two ice cubes, called
the stress tolerance.
So you just hold an ice cube in your
hand until it burns a little bit.
That physical pain slows
down the emotional brain,
and you have a little
window before you act there.
So that's a little secret.
ANNA BARTUSKA: That's amazing.
I'm going to ask one more
quick follow-up question.
You've mentioned this term, emotional
brain and thinking brain, a lot.
Can you tell us a little bit more about
the science behind those two terms
and what you mean when you say that?
LUANA MARQUES: So the way
I think about the brain,
and it's much more
complicated than this,
but I try to think of
things very simplistically.
There's two parts of our
brain that are always
competing for energy and attention.
Our thinking brain,
the prefrontal cortex,
which helps us to do a
math problem, execute plan.
And then the old lizard brain, which
is the amygdala, the limbic system,
which really is the fight, flight,
or freeze part of the brain.
And if you put me in MRI machine
and gave me a bunch of math problems
and I was solving really well, and then
you showed me a picture of a big lion,
[INAUDIBLE] my reaction
time would go down.
And so the way I think
about it is, when one is on,
the other one tends to be off,
or like offline a little bit.
And so you always want
to sort of be playing
with your brain to be able to
do what Mike was talking about.
We need to be training our brain.
That's why I like talking
about brain health,
instead of mental health, because
the brain's just another organ,
and it can be actually
trained to work for us.
Does that help, Anna?
ANNA BARTUSKA: That does.
Thank you for those tips.
I'm curious going back to
this kind of brain training
and pivoting a little bit to Michael's
kind of analogy, too, of painting
this picture, how do we actually start
to change these patterns, Michael?
Like, how would you, how do we
foster this masterpiece of self
then in your work?
MICHAEL PUETT: Absolutely.
I would, and this is in full
agreement with Luana's way
of putting this, which
is beautiful, I would
say you begin with the seemingly
most ludicrously mundane
aspects of your daily life.
Because that's where
these patterns set in.
And that's where we need to change them.
So when I say ludicrously
mundane, I mean literally down
to when you were walking down a
street, notice how little of what
is around you you're
actually even seeing.
When you're interacting with people,
notice how little of real interaction
is actually occurring, including with
very close friends and family members.
Note the degree to which your just
daily interactions or just, again,
these rote patterns.
Note the degree to which your
emotions are these rote patterns.
As we sadly know, family patterns can
set in and can continue for decades,
and even move on to the next generation.
I mean, it's chilling the
degree to which we do this.
Now, that's the negative part, so
immediately jumping to the good part,
getting back to the heart
of your question, Anna.
So, how do we break this?
You go back to that mundane level.
When you're walking down
a street on a daily basis,
start training yourself to really
see what's going on around you.
And this is training.
You will not normally be doing this.
If you try to think back,
what is your office space
like where you work every day?
You probably can say
very little about it.
What is the street like that you
walk to the bus every day on?
You probably don't know, even
though you walk on it every day.
You start training yourself
to start seeing things.
When you're interacting
with people, you start
training yourself to start
really relating to them,
as opposed to relating by rote pattern.
You begin to see, oh, this person who's
just mean, and that person is nice,
you begin to realize you're in a pattern
where in the latter case, it's nice,
that's good, but this
person who's mean, you're
probably doing something that's pulling
out that negative energy from them.
So you're training yourself to
begin to really relate to them.
You're beginning to sense, what
am I doing that's drawing out
that person's anger or resentment.
How do I shift this with
this family member who I just
keep having this daily fight with?
How can I shift that a little bit by
simply playing with different emotions,
taking on different roles with that
person, shifting how I interact
with them?
Oftentimes, at the most ludicrously
basic level at the beginning,
just using different tones of voice,
using different body language.
These seemingly mundane things,
once you begin working with them,
you begin realizing you can really
shift the degree to which you're
relating to the world around
you, to people around you.
And once you begin to
sense that shift, then you
can begin doing it at
an even higher level.
You can begin really working
on your relationships,
really getting a sense of why
with my coworker, just involved
in this constant jealousy
resentment competitive battle.
And it's amazing how these
seemingly unchangeable relationships
can be altered dramatically
within literally a few weeks.
It's incredible.
And families maybe takes a few months,
but still, it is absolutely doable.
But again, you begin with the most
mundane aspects of your daily life.
And then you begin working from there.
LUANA MARQUES: I love this.
ANNA BARTUSKA: I do, too.
LUANA MARQUES: The reason I love
this, Mike, for many, many years,
whenever I started to
work with a new client,
they wanted, everybody
wants to advance fast.
We all do, that's the human condition.
And I'd say to them, how often do you
even notice your shower in the morning.
Because most of us are having
an argument with somebody
later in the day on that shower.
Or like brushing your teeth.
How many people actually pay
attention to brushing their teeth?
Most of the time, you're already
on to-do list, six things ahead,
trying to get something else done.
And so actually think there
is magic on the mundane,
because those are the moments
that we wake up to oh,
my God, my life is
automatic pilot so much.
And if we can't even
notice those moments,
then it's really hard to
change the more complex thing.
So I love your answer.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Yeah, I really
appreciate both your answers.
To play just a little bit of
devil's advocate and the thought
that I had coming to mind,
my own chatter pattern
here, is, are we missing
anything by being in the present?
And I mean that, and by starting
to notice some of these patterns
more, like the conversation you
mentioned, Luana, about in the future,
talking with trying to plan
something, if we're always
noticing what is around us, do we lose
anything by not being able to plan?
Help me break that down further.
LUANA MARQUES: I don't
think we're losing anything.
I think we are thriving.
Because we are not, I don't think either
Mike and I are saying one of the costs
that, of course, we have to
have moments of planning.
But let me just argue that the shower
perhaps, is a great place to think.
But also, sometimes we're
just replaying things.
We're not actually planning.
We're really in that anxious brain just
ruminating or thinking about thinking
or just worrying about something,
versus what would look different
would be like, OK, I have
a presentation later today
and I'm just running
through my presentation.
That's planning, that's practicing.
But that's not-- the argument
I think we're both making,
is this idea that automatic pilot robs
you the ability to just be present.
And actually, it takes a lot more
energy to worry than to be present.
And once you're present,
your sleep is better,
you engage in a way that's
much more meaningful.
And so I don't I don't think it robs us.
Michael, what do you think?
MICHAEL PUETT: I fully agree.
So often when we think of plans,
we think of them in the sense
that well, it's the way
to get ahead in life
is that if I decide well in
advance I want to do X, Y, and Z,
so well in advance can mean what I
want to become 20 years from now.
But it can also mean, what I'll do in
that meeting that I have later today.
Either way, we're focused on that plan.
And then everything is aimed at
trying to get us to that point.
The danger is exactly
as you said, Luana.
That means we are literally
not seeing anything going on
around us, because we're so focused on
being that X. At the meeting or that
X in 20 years.
And everything is aimed at
that, which means precisely
because we're not seeing what's
going on around us, we literally
cease to interact with those around us.
We cease to see what is around us.
And it means we cease to
be open to possibilities.
So going to the extreme
example, that in 20 years
I will be X, well, if you're really
open to the world around you,
there are probably,
I'll take out probably.
There are possibilities that will
be opening up to you constantly
that you will literally never ever see.
And precisely by being
open to them, that
is what will allow you to really grow.
Now, are you planning?
Yes.
But in a very different way
than we usually use that term.
Then you are really growing as a human
being in this incredibly creative mode
that we've been mentioning.
And that is how you can really be
something extraordinary in 20 years,
or even at that meeting
later in the day.
Because you're living your life
and you'll be more fully present.
So I agree completely.
It sounds like a paradox
to say by being more
present you can be more
fully open to the future,
but I think it is absolutely the case.
ANNA BARTUSKA: That's
radical, and so helpful.
We have a few more questions coming in.
I want to try to get to some
of them before our time is up.
And I think one of
these links a little bit
to what we've been talking about in
terms of potentially being present,
and also kind of when our brain
starts to run about different things.
The question is, "What can we do
to care less about other people's
negative opinions?"
I'm seeing smiles from both of you.
Who wants to jump in?
MICHAEL PUETT: Luana, please.
LUANA MARQUES: Sure.
I mean, there's two types of, I'm going
to b e very sort of black and white.
But there's two ways we can
choose to live our lives.
One is an emotion-driven life, and
the other one is a value-driven life.
And whenever we care a lot
about what other people think,
we're very likely in a
narrative about ourselves
that's being run by our own emotions.
And so it's really this idea
of shifting your perspective.
So, in my book, Bold Move,
which is coming out next week,
I talk very openly about
the shifts I have to make.
And what do I mean by shifting?
It's really learning
to talk to yourself as
if you're talking to your best friend.
It's becoming a bit of a detective.
It's questioning the
narrative in our brains.
And so if we are really,
really caring, it
means we're saying
something about ourselves.
Very likely something like, I'm
not enough, I'm not good enough,
I'm unlovable.
And that narrative is really
what's feeding your insecurities
about what other people think of you.
And that's why I said
a few minutes earlier,
it's really important
to work on the self
before you work on the
context around you.
Because both need work.
But if you're walking around
with lenses that are distorted,
I think of them as like glasses.
It's like we have magnifying glasses on.
We've worn them for so
long that we are not
even aware of what we're
saying to ourselves.
And so, it's time to take the glasses
off, literally, and really examine
what the narrative in your brain is.
Shift, talk to yourself
as if you're best friend.
And last thing I'll say,
and I'll throw it to you,
Michael, is thoughts are not facts.
Let me say that again.
Thoughts are not facts.
I know we want them to be
facts, but they're not.
They are just something that
we're coming up in our brain.
And if it's arbitrary anyhow, why do
we have to be so mean to ourselves?
ANNA BARTUSKA: Such a good question.
I really appreciate that response.
I think it's really, really helpful.
And I appreciate both of your tips that
you're kind of giving throughout this.
I think there's so much
richness, and I hope
everyone is taking notes as much
as I am, too, while doing this.
So we've had a few questions come up,
and I'd love to hear from both of you
about your views on meditation.
Specifically, the
questions are around, do
you feel it can help reduce
anxiety if practiced regularly.
Do you think that we can improve mental
health and well-being by meditation.
And just your general views on it.
Michael, let's start with you.
MICHAEL PUETT: Sure.
I'll answer with an
emphatic yes, absolutely.
But let me also mention a danger of
the ways that we will often do it.
So, a danger of the ways
we often do meditation
is simply to say, OK, to deal with all
of my stress and unhappiness and anger
and resentment and blah blah,
blah, blah, blah, our normal lives,
the way we deal with that is
stopping for a few moments,
breathing deeply, calming down.
And then that will give me the strength
to return to my life unchanged.
And needless to say,
that's not the goal.
The goal is not to calm yourself down so
you can live your life, your miserable
life, unchanged.
The goal is to change how
you're living your life.
And so meditation works if you do
the work of what that really means,
which is, it has to affect what happens
when you walk out of that meditation
room or off of that mat
where you do your meditation
or in the corner where
you're breathing deeply.
It is not helping if it doesn't
really affect how you live your life.
And that's the key.
So, meditation can help,
but only if then when
you are dealing with
your daily life, you're
really using that momentary calm you
felt to really alter your patterns,
really work with the world.
If you're simply calming yourself
down to continue with life unchanged,
then it can be downright dangerous.
You're just giving yourself a good drug
to be able to make it through your life
without changing anything.
So the key is, you must do, going
back to Luana's key point here,
you must do that work on a daily
basis to really alter your life.
And meditation is helpful
if it's part of that program
of allowing you to do so.
LUANA MARQUES: I love this.
I can't tell you how many people I've
worked with that avoid the meditation.
They're like, if I just meditate,
then it's going to be fine.
You're just avoiding discomfort.
And there's no life without discomfort.
And so there's so much science showing
that meditation can change our brain.
But the work is on
and off that question.
And off is perhaps even more
important than on the question.
I love your point, Michael.
That's so true.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Really helpful.
Thank you so much.
I have one more question that
I'd like to pose to both of you
that I think is an excellent question
that we got from the audience
to wrap us up today.
You both have different courses talking
about happiness and living a good life,
talking about managing anxiety
and living a bold life.
And so the final question
for today is, can we
be happy and live with
anxiety at the same time?
Michael, I'll start with you.
MICHAEL PUETT: Wonderful question.
And the answer is, absolutely.
And let me even introduce
another term here
coming from the Chinese
tradition, which is joy.
And what they mean by joy is,
often when we think of happiness,
you can have a deep happiness
that is joyous in the way
that they will define it--
--but often when we think of
things like happiness and anxiety
and anger and resentment, all of our
usual emotional responses to the world,
the sense is, we try
to think, OK, I want
more of the moments when I feel
happy and fewer of the moments
when I'm feeling anxious.
And the view that will come in from this
notion of joy is, what you're trying
to get is this deep feeling of joy.
It's this deep connection.
Joy here, the Chinese
term is the same as music.
I think it's like resonating
musically with those around you,
with the world around you.
That's what you're trying to get.
Now, getting back to the heart of
the question, that doesn't mean
horrible things won't happen to you.
Of course, it's life.
Horrible things will happen to you.
You'll be sad, you'll be
anxious, that will happen.
But what you're training
yourself to reach,
is a point where that
anxiety isn't debilitating.
And again, going back to the heart
of what we've been mentioning,
that anxiety isn't a product
of your patterns in life.
It's simply a momentary thing you feel.
You sense the pattern playing
out, you work against it.
Something horrible happens.
Of course, it's sad, but
then you work around that,
because you have this depth of joy
that you've been training yourself
for years to slowly develop.
And therefore, getting back
to the heart of the question,
the answer is emphatically yes.
But not, again, in the
happiness and the sense
that we often use it, like
something good happened, I'm happy.
I found an ice cream cone in
my fridge that tastes good.
I feel momentarily happy.
Sure, that can exist with
anxiety, but you're just,
emotions are going back and forth.
What you're seeking is
this joyousness that
allows you to sense that great
happiness, work with the anxiety
and work with all of the other
emotions, because it comes out
of this depth of joy.
LUANA MARQUES: So agree.
You know, my grandmother
used to describe this
as when people are changing,
they tend to be like a rock.
They want to stay where they are.
And to Michael's point, it's
like this black and white.
I mean, they're happy or sad.
And my grandmother used to
say that to have a happy life,
you have to be more like the water.
That you go around the rock, you go on
top, you go on bottom, you're flexible.
And in my brain, that's
cognitive flexibility.
It's that ability of handling
the challenging moments of life
with more grace, with
more skills, actually.
And knowing that there are
going to be ups and downs,
but if we practice the skills that
Mike and I have been talking about,
you are much better
prepared to handle the lows.
And you can really be present
in those moments of joy.
And I love the idea of joy
even more, because it's
those little micro moments
when you look at somebody,
you have been working all day, and I
try to practice this the end of my day,
when I go see my kid, I
like to really look at him.
Can I have a little moment
of just being present?
Because often, we just
going on to the next thing.
And so I think we can live
incredible life with anxiety,
as long as we are moving towards
the things that matter the most.
As long as we are value-driven
and we are present.
And honestly, you make
the anxiety work for you.
At least, I do.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Thank you so much.
Thank you, Luana, and thank you,
Michael, for sharing your time,
your wisdom, for being present, for
helping us all break out of patterns
during this, and think in new ways.
And this is just a small
part of how we're changing.
And so we are so grateful.
Thank you so much for
everyone that tuned in today.
Thank you for all of your questions.
I wish we could have
gotten to them all, but I
encourage you to continue
to grapple with this topic
and mull it over by
participating in the course.
Michael's course is currently
live, "The Path to Happiness."
And so go ahead and start that today.
The Bold Move is released.
Dr. Luana's book is
released next Tuesday.
And her course launches on June 28.
And so again, just encourage
you to enroll in both of those.
You will get a discount
code for being part
of this presentation in the
next day or so to your email.
And so we look forward to seeing
you in both of those courses.
Thank you all so much.
LUANA MARQUES: Thank you, Anna.
Michael, it's so great
to be here with you.
MICHAEL PUETT: Thank you, Luana.
It's been wonderful to be
here with you and Anna.
Thank you so much for
your wonderful work.
ANNA BARTUSKA: Of course.
I'll hand it back over to
the Harvard Online team.
Thank you to everyone
who made this run today.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
Thank you, Anna, thank you,
Dr. Luana, thank you, Michael.
And also, thank you to all of you who
have joined us from around the world
today.
We hope you'll join us inside
these wonderful courses, "Building
Personal Resilience" and
"The Path To Happiness."
If you've registered for and
attended this presentation,
you'll receive a discount code in
your inbox in the next day or so.
And you can also find the discount
code and link in the chat.
Just as a reminder, the content
provided in this webinar
is intended for
informational purposes only
and should not be considered
as medical advice.
The content is not and should not
be relied upon as medical advice,
and should not be used to
make a clinical diagnosis,
to provide treatment, or to replace
or overrule a licensed health care
provider's judgment.
Thanks again.
Goodbye, everyone, and
see you again soon.